[Music]
guys League of Legends can be a
beautiful fun and rewarding game
experience except when it's not and it
tilts you off the face of the [ __ ]
earth I mean with over a hundred and
forty champions in the game at this
point some of them are just bound to
piss you off which is why we thought it
would be fun and even a little cathartic
to rank the top ten League of Legends
champions that will tilt you off the
face of the earth
get ready for some salt on this one
junglers wake up in cold sweats after
nightmares about the number 10 champion
on our list nunu and his yeti Willem
will terrorize your side of the jungle
and there's nothing you can do about it
[Music]
right away with his hearty health bar
and consumed to ensure he always gets
your buff all you can do is watch as
your side of the jungle disappears in
front of your eyes if you really wanted
to he could flash consume smite or just
consume spa he's gonna get it walk stop
faked it right in his face
that's what dudu does look at me short
undercut - no although his kid has
changed a few times throughout the years
one thing has stayed constant nunu is a
real dick to other junglers
the title trickster fizz sales his way
into the number nine spot on our list
fizz is a fairly standard melee assassin
he can deal a ton of damage in a short
amount of time but what makes him a true
vessel for animosity is his Eve
[Music]
the fine is boosted broken [ __ ] at 80
[ __ ] what the [ __ ]
playful tricksters seize fizz jump up
onto his Trident and become untargetable
for a short amount of time even
resetting turret aggro
[Music]
oh my god which is all the time he needs
to make you disappear frankly you don't
even get a chance to play the game
against fizz - he gets low enough that
they could kill him during the cocoons
duration and we have some wow it's gonna
get killed we're still follows the flash
[Applause]
get off a dive teleport available for
sim five Chum the waters and Baker will
not be able to get out
you rascal
[Applause]
the support that feels more like an
assassin Pike has harpoon D number eight
spot on our list now think about it he
has a hook to pull enemies in a dash
with a built-in stun and invisibility
we're coming back in a vault hook him
get over here scorpion style baby that's
pretty arrogant I like that and on top
of all that he's got an execute with a
cool-down reset he doesn't even have to
worry about whiny ad carry players
either since any kill with his old gives
full kill gold to an assisting Ally I
guess very difficult to get away from
those water dive forward where's the
funkier to go for those of you move to
League of Legends you may not have the
same level of PTSD caused by the number
7 entry on our list
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Laughter]
jegos entire game plan revolves around
filling a bush with jack-in-the-box
traps baiting you in with his
invisibility and hallucination and
watching you die a slow and humiliating
death
it's a trap
[Music]
he may be weaker away from his traps but
nothing is worse than stumbling onto
three or four of them on your way to a
jungle boy
[Music]
easiest game of my life they said what
what
are you [ __ ] me the speedy chemist
cinge is blazing a chem trail straight
to number six on our list
he'll fling you over his head stick you
in some curiously sticky goo and lead
you on a poisonous wild-goose chase
until your health bar slowly ticks down
to zero holy [ __ ] what you got oh you're
[ __ ] Charlie Charlie are you running
why are you running
seriously everybody knows not to chase a
singed yep
somehow no one seems to have put those
teachings into practice sometimes
positivity makes people hate you even
more and our number five champion
exemplifies that Zoe's paddle star might
as well be a hydrogen bomb that she can
hit from two screens away and that's
before she hits you with a two-second
sleep and then am I reading this right
double damage Oh
dude wait wait is this actually a thing
you might think you're safe after a
tactical flash over the wall but she can
just steal it and follow you without
even burning her own he's not pushing
that out as g2 have set up all these
plays in the talk sided now his Majesty
the Ripper King lands in at number four
on our list let's cut to the chase here
tahm Kench is an absolute buzzkill
that's how misses for the way back into
this game oh you want to gank that
vulnerable ad carry I don't think so
about to make a cool out play in a
teamfight nope whatever inspired plays
you were planning to make get canceled
out by a well-placed devourer from this
champion
exceptional survivability and the
ability to teleport himself and a
teammate across the map make tahm Kench
a nightmare to deal with what they want
out of it they wanted to get spin on top
of it but not quite misty walks up gives
a little lick in the bush and they walk
away
someday continues pushing up the bottom
side and now ho Glee forced to flash the
wall get some good looks and game to it
fortunately Bona is here again this is
his rim and he is gonna get another kill
for his team professor Cecil P
Heimerdinger cracks our list at number
three as an infuriating opponent to face
off against in Lane
you know I'm something of a scientist
myself he's incredible pushing power
means you'll be locked under your turret
for the foreseeable future and on the
off chance you're always negligent
jungler appears heimer is pretty damn
slippery when he's around his turrets
which should be all the time unless of
course he just blows you up instead
basically dropping down asteroids and
solely took down that turtle what this
is the take oh here we go guys we're
gonna contesta blue the damages uh-huh
our runner-up spot belongs to the Cloe
mortal hell spawn known as Teemo the
Swift Scout has been at the center of
summoners and nightmares for so long we
did an entire video just about him
sometimes you play against a monster and
anyone who picks Teemo is that monster
it looks like he's making it grapes
mistake
no no come back oh yeah with blinding
poison to mitigate auto-attack damage
invisibility after standing still and
nucular mushrooms that seemed to be in
every bush on the map after level six
teemo has all the tools to send even the
calmest league player straight over the
edge as if there was any doubt the
slippery edge Lord swordsmen known as
Yasuo dashes his way in at number one on
our list he may have a pretty high skill
ceiling but even the unwashed masses
seem to make him look pretty damn good
on the rift
I mean the guy dashes circles through
teamfights he's got a wind wall to block
any projectile face damage a guaranteed
knock up combo with his ulti close range
and enough crit chance and armor
penetration to turn even the tatanka's
front line into artisanal sashimi
here we go those two versus one up top
on York since squishy target they might
be able to capitalize oh he goes back in
oh oh he goes back in the key Lee's
gonna be there will he actually be able
to rock this out who thought double kill
this shouldn't kill him and he makes it
out alive guys we really need to stop
doing these top ten annoying character
videos they're just pissing me off
watching them back this want to play
like a fun chill game like Magic the
Gathering or something thanks for
watching if you want more great content
just like this be sure to hit the
subscribe button
[Music]
you